[Musik]
die folgende Frage macht den
Sicherheitsexperten im Westen vielleicht
mehr Sorgen als der Ukraine Krieg wie
kann man dazu bringen seine Politik der
Konfrontation gegen demokratische Länder
zu beenden wie um alles in der Welt
können wir verhindern dass das
totalitäre Regime in Peking zu einer
Bedrohung für uns alle wird ihr denkt
ich würde übertreiben dann hört euch
einfach mal das folgende an
sagt er bereite China auf einen Krieg
vor die Welt sollte ihn ernst nehmen im
März sprach sie in vier verschiedenen
reden über das Thema Kriegsbereitschaft
und forderte seine Generäle in einer
davon auf den Kampf zu wagen seine
Regierung kündigte außerdem eine
Erhöhung des chinesischen
Verteidigungshaushalts um 7,2 % an
während der letzten Monate hat Peking
neue Gesetze zum militärischen
Bereitschaft neue Luftschutzbunker in
Städten jedes der mir enge von Taiwan
und neue Büros für die nationale
verteidigungsmobilisierung im ganzen
Land vorgestellt in Peking hat sich eine
Änderung vollzogen die politische
Entscheidungsträger und
Wirtschaftsführer weltweit nicht
ignorieren können wenn Ski sagt dass er
sich auf einen Krieg vorbereite wäre es
töricht ihn nicht beim Wort zu nehmen
es steht eine Wende bevor wie sie seit
100 Jahren nicht mehr stattgefunden hat
und wir treiben diese Wände gemeinsam
voran skijimping zu Wladimir Putin am 22
März 2023 während seines Staatsbesuchs
in Moskau
das Thema der chinesischen Wende ist
heute mehr denn je aktuell nachdenkschau
pfingstwende hat China einen enormen
Wandel durchgemacht es folgten
Jahrzehnte rasanten Wachstum sowie
technologische und militärische
Modernisierung doch das Regime Champion
ist nun von der Idee einer ganz anderen
Wende besessen China soll zu einer neuen
Supermarkt werden und zwar ohne
Rücksicht auf Verluste es soll eine
Macht werden die es mit den Vereinigten
Staaten aufnehmen kann um der
Vorherrschaft des bestens mit seinen
dekadenten Werten endlich ein Ende zu
setzen soll wieder der Nabel der Welt
sein die Herrschaft und Ideologie der
kommunistischen Parteien hast soll also
weltweit politisch gesellschaftlicher
Maßstab etabliert werden
aus diesem Grund versucht das rote
Riesenreich einen politischen
wirtschaftlichen militärischen und sogar
seinen kulturellen Einfluss zu
vergrößern das Problem dabei China ist
immer noch eine totalitäre Diktatur in
der universelle Menschenrechte als
ballastgeld und diese Tatsache sollte
uns alle beunruhigen vor allem seit
Präsident an der Macht es verhält sich
das Land immer feindlicher und
aggressiver gegenüber dem Westen und
gegenüber seinen Nachbarn
[Musik]
die Geschichte mit den chinesischen
spionageballon war da nur eine klitze
kleine Spitze eines gewaltigen Eisbergs
das Ding Überflug auf seiner Route aber
immerhin die ziellos amerikanischer
Atomraketen in Montana und weitere
militärische Anlagen ausgestatte war der
Ballon mit Antennen und Zensoren
zusammen von Informationen und zum
Abfangen von Nachrichten ein f22-jährige
holte ihn dann vom Himmel wie das US
Außenministerium bestätigt hat der
ballonhersteller direkte Beziehungen zum
chinesischen Militär
chinesischer Ballon trug laut den USA
Antennen und andere Ausrüstung zum
Sammeln von Informationen die USA
bereiten Maßnahmen gegen Einrichtungen
vor die mit den chinesischen Ballon
Überwachungsprogramm in Verbindung
stehen sagt ein Beamter aber dieser
Ballon war nicht der einzige und auch
nicht der erste seiner Art schon
mehrfach sind chinesische Balance über
den USA und Kanada geflogen schon unter
Trump soll es solche Fälle gegeben haben
offenbar handelt es sich um eine Flotte
von spionageballons und spionagegeräten
die auch in Südamerika und Europa
unterwegs waren das ist natürlich ein
Grund zur Sorge aber diese Balance sind
nicht der gefährlichste oder beunruhigen
Aspekt der chinesischen Aktivitäten
gegen den Westen sie stellten halt nur
eine nette und griffige Story da die gut
für die Nachrichten geeignet ist für den
gewöhnlichen Medienkonsumenten weniger
griffig da extrem komplex und abstrakt
sind da schon Cyberattacken diese sind
aber viel schlimmer als nur ein paar
Balance und sie kommen schon seit Jahren
so häufig vor dass der damalige FBI
Direktor James Komik sich 2014 folgenden
bitteren Scherz erlaubte es gibt zwei
Arten von großen Unternehmen in den
Vereinigten Staaten diejenigen die von
den Chinesen gehackt wurden und
diejenigen die nicht wissen dass sie von
den Chinesen gehackt wurden
chinesisches cyberspione haben die USA
systematisch angegriffen und infiltriert
sie haben Industriedesigns
Geschäftsgeheimnis und alle möglichen
vertraulichen Informationen gestohlen
von US-Unternehmen und auch von der
US-Regierung selbst sie haben sogar
hochgradig geheimes Material in die
Hände bekommen etwa Konstruktionspläne
für Amerikas F35 Kampfjet die euch
vorstellen könnt war man in Washington
nicht im News darüber und ist es bis
heute nicht erinnert euch noch daran als
die US-Regierung den Kauf von Huawei
Gerät US-Unternehmen aufforderte keine
Produkte von Huawei zu verwenden als
Grund wurde aufgeführt dass die Chinesen
mittels der Geräte von Huawei in der
Lage sein die USA auszuschnüffeln wir
haben über dieses Gefahrenpotenzial
damals sogar ein eigenes Video gedreht
dass ihr euch später anschauen könnt
dass dieses Thema nach wie vor Brand
heiß und hochgradig sicherheitskritisch
ist gleichzeitig aber zum Beispiel von
der deutschen Politik sträflich war
nachlässigt und unterschätzt wird zeigen
Nachrichten wie diese
Dritter April 2023 Deutschlands oberste
cybersicherheitsbehörde setzt
huawei-technik ein das Bundesamt für
Sicherheit in der Informationstechnik
BSI sitzt Behörden intern auf
Technologie des umstrittenen
chinesischen Netzwerkausrüsters Huawei
außerdem nutze die Behörde die
telekommunikationskomponenten der Firma
Alcatel Lucien Enterprise einem
Unternehmen das mehrheitlich zum
Staatskonzern china gehört der Vorgang
ist brisante nicht nur weil das DSi zu
einem wesentlichen Teil für die
cybersicherheit der Bundesrepublik
zuständig ist sondern auch weil
chinesische IT-Konzerne wie Huawei oder
sieht die seit geraumer zeitkritisch
gesehen werden zur Vorsicht bei way und
anderen chinesischen Konzernen meinte
kürzlich auch der Vizepräsident des
Verfassungsschutzes
finanzszenarien die uns Probleme
bereiten können und er glaube nicht dass
diese Dimension allen Bewusstsein der
CSU digitale Politiker reinhard Brandl
übte vor diesem Hintergrund scharfe
Kritik an Innenministerin nennt sie
Feser erwarte SPD Politikerin vor
chinesischen Unternehmen mit Ängsten
Verbindungen zur kommunistischen Partei
freie Hand zu lassen Frau Feser und die
Ampel scheinen vollständig den Überblick
verloren zu haben sagte Brandl im
Handelsblatt aber so wie es aussieht
geht der Konflikt zwischen China und die
besten weit über Spionage hinaus Pekings
konfrontative Agenda steckt auch hinter
Nachrichten wie dieser
Handelsdaten zeigen dass China Russlands
Krieg in der Ukraine unterstützt trotz
Sanktionen rüstet Moskau seine
Kampfflugzeuge U-Boote und Soldaten mit
Hilfe chinesischer Unternehmen aus China
trägt die Sanktion gegen Russland nicht
mit und schick den Russen auch noch
Gerätschaft für den Krieg es handelt
sich dabei unter anderem um
navigationsausrüstung für russische
Hubschrauber Ausrüstung zu stören der
Kommunikation und teile die ihren su 35
Kampfflugzeugen verwendet werden können
bei den chinesischen Lieferungen an
Russland handelt es sich hauptsächlich
um dual use Ausrüstung die sowohl für
militärische als auch für zivile Zwecke
genutzt werden kann und was ist davon zu
halten
und wir haben es hier mit einem
klassischen doppelten Spiel zu tun den
Westen nicht massiv verärgern aber Putin
dennoch ein paar Brocken hinwerfen denn
wohlgemerkt China schickt keine Waffen
im großen Stil nach Russland was ist
durchaus könnte denn sein doppeltes
Spiel spielt es eben auch mit dem Kreml
China kann Russland Waffen liefern die
ihm in der Ukraine einen Vorteil
verschaffen könnten warum hat es das
noch nicht getan in der Tat verfügt
Peking über reichlich militärische
Ausrüstung und Munition russischer
Bauart die dazu beitragen könnten den
Kampf zugunsten des Krems zu entscheiden
anstatt aber Russland voreilig
militärische Rüstung für den
unmittelbaren Bedarf in der Ukraine zu
schicken wird China eher die
militärische Zusammenarbeit ausbauen um
seine langfristigen Ziele im Wettbewerb
mit den USA zu erreichen Russland
braucht Hightech und die Chinesen haben
einen Druckmittel gegen Russland in der
Hand was könnten Sie von Russland im
Gegenzug bekommen china will einfach das
Beste für sich herausschlagene Moment
ist es für picking eben strategisch das
klügste Russland schön satteln zu lassen
denn Moskau hat sowieso niemand anderen
der ihm helfen könnte die Frage ist
jedoch ob nicht die Möglichkeit besteht
dass sich diese Einschätzung in Zukunft
ändert zum Beispiel dann wenn Russland
tatsächlich der totale Knockout auf der
Weltbühne droht und aus diesem Grund
zählt man im Westen eins und eins
zusammen man sieht die Gefahr dass China
seine Position von heute auf morgen
ändern und Russland aktiv mit massiven
Waffenlieferungen helfen könnte
blinken sagt china könnte Waffen an
Russland liefern China erwägt Russland
Waffen und Munition für den Ukraine
Krieg zu liefern das sagte
US-Außenminister Antony blinken
Deutschland stolz sagt China werde keine
Waffen an Russland liefern die
Äußerungen von Scholz über Peking kam
überraschend da China die Möglichkeit
von Waffenlieferung an Russland nicht
öffentlich zurückgewiesen hat der
Bundeskanzler deutete jedoch anders
Peking Deals Deutschland direkt zugesagt
habe der Chef der EU-Außenpolitik Joseph
parallel erhielt im letzten Monat
ähnliche private Zusicherungen wo er
sagte wir müssen trotzdem Wasser bleiben
klar ist die Führung in Peking würde
keinerleiste Gruppe haben Moskau massiv
mit Waffen zu beliefern wenn sie sich
damit eine strategischen Vorteil
verschaffen könnten und deswegen
bereiten sich die Alliierten für diesen
Fall bereits ausgiebig vor
2 März 2023 starkes Sanktion gegen China
drohen wenn von der Leyen beiden in den
USA Treffen der spreche des Nationalen
Sicherheitsrats schon Kirby sagt am
Donnerstag in eine Pressekonferenz das
nicht nur die USA sondern auch unsere
Verbündeten und Partner über Instrumente
verfügen sollte hier versuchen Waffen
nach Russland zu schicken der
niederländische außen ist aber auch
sagte militärische Unterstützung für das
kaum wird Konsequenzen haben ich möchte
allen Kolleginnen und Kollegen auch
meinen chinesischen sagen dass die
Wahrheit hier nicht irgendwo in der
Mitte liegt es gibt nur ein Land das
verantwortlich ist und das ist Russland
und wir sind noch nicht fertig mit
Chinas bedrohlichen Aktionen da wird
Demokratie in Hongkong quasi abgeschafft
und Taiwan immer wieder mit Krieg
bedroht letzteres hat in den vergangenen
Jahren massiv zugenommen mittlerweile
waren hochrangige US Militär ist das
China mit einer Invasion der Insel nicht
mehr allzu lange warten dürfte also
passende Chinas Provokation mal zusammen
spionageballons Cyber-Attacken
Zusammenarbeit mit Russland Besetzung
von Hongkong und ständige Drohungen
gegen Taiwan und gegen Litauen ja ihr
habt richtig gehört das von China weit
entfernte litauen ist bei Peking in
Ungnade gefallen und wird mit Sanktionen
bestraft was war passiert die Litauer
hatten ist gewagt eine diplomatische
Vertretung Taiwans in ihre Hauptstadt
Vilnius zu errichten ihr seht Chinas Arm
reicht weit und man meint es nicht gut
mit dem freien Westen sein regiert
verhält sich das Land fast schon offen
feindselig in seiner Außenpolitik was
also kann getan werden um Peking zu
stoppen welche Maßnahmen könnten die USA
und die EU ergreifen um ein solches
Handeln zu bestrafen oder zu verhindern
an dieser Stelle stellt sich natürlich
die Frage nach Sanktion kann also Shisha
banks imperialistischer Sanktion
gestoppt werden und wäre sowas überhaupt
klug all diese Fragen werden im heutigen
Video beantworten dazu müssen wir uns
aber zunächst einmal mit dem Sinn und
Zweck von Sanktionen befassen also auf
geht's
Sanktionen haben Konjunktur
[Musik]
sind Wirtschaftssanktionen wirklich
sinnvoll und effektiv und erfüllen sie
einen Zweck diese Debatte ist nicht neu
sie wird schon seit mindestens 2500
Jahren geführt eine der ersten
dokumentierten wirtschaftsaktion ist das
Dekret von Megara aus dem Jahr 432 vor
Christus es war der Vorabend des
Peloponnesischen Krieges in dem Athen
gegen spartakämpfte mit dem Dekret
verboten den Handel mit der Stadt das
ist die Häfen des von Athen geführten
Städte Bundesbahn für Kaufleute aus
Megara Tabu und viele Historiker sehen
dieses Sanktion als einem der Auslöser
für den Peloponnesischen Krieg
[Musik]
ein viel jüngeres Beispiel ist eine
Sanktion gegen Italien aus den Jahren
1935 damals bestrafte der Völker und der
Italiener für die Invasion der
äthiopischen Region a bis zienien es
handelte sich dabei um ein mildes
handelsemago für bestimmte rüstungsgüte
und um eine Kreditsperre Italien konnte
diese Maßnahmen leicht umgehen indem es
weiter mit Nation Handel trieb die nicht
den Völkerbund angehörten und natürlich
gab es in der Zeit des Zweiten Weltkrieg
Sanktion gegen das japanische
Kaiserreich und gegen Nazi Deutschland
aber erst seine 1950er Jahren wurden
Sanktionen zu einem wirklich häufig
angewandten Instrument der Politik z.B
gegen das Apartheid Regie in Südafrika
gegen Iran der erotasi in Libyen oder
gegen Nordkorea
dieser Grafik könnt ihr entnehmen wie
wirtschaftliche Strafen immer beliebter
geworden sind vor allem in den 2000er
Jahren gab es in Folge des 11 septembers
und durch den Krieg gegen den Terror
nochmals einen Aufschwung bei Sanktionen
mittlerweile sanktioniert man auch
Drogenhändler oder Personen die mit
Ihnen in Verbindung stehen soll die
Strafen gegen das kolumbianische
carnikarte sind so einfallen es wird
euch nicht überraschen dass die
wirtschaftlichen Strafen vor allem von
den USA initiiert werden Amis haben nun
mal durch den globalen Einfluss des
Dollars und er macht ihre eigenen
Finanzsystems die größten Hebel für
Sanktionen in der Hand in dieser Tabelle
sind die US Sanktion gegen
länderunternehmen und Einzelpersonen aus
allen Teilen der Welt zusammengefasst
schaut euch an wie sie sich in den
letzten 20 Jahren entwickelt haben und
wenn wir das Jahr 2022 mit Sanktionen
gegen Russland wird einbeziehen würden
wäre der Anstiegen noch größer
trotzdem bleibt die Frage funktionieren
Sanktionen überhaupt nun das hängt davon
ab welche Ziele man damit überhaupt
verfolgt vor kurzem haben wir in einem
Video hier gezeigt dass die Sanktion
gegen Russland trotz anders lautender
Stimmen große Erfolge erzielt haben und
noch erzielen werden sie schwächen die
russische Wirtschaft in ihrem Wachstum
das Land in der Fähigkeit Krieg zu
führen und das war ja schließlich das
Ziel wer aber meint man müsse mit
Sanktionen eine gegnerische Wirtschaft
quasi vernichten nun das funktioniert
nicht es gilt hier im übrigen die
Sanktion so zu dosieren dass sie nicht
zum bumeranger werden oder eigenen
Wirtschaft mehr Schaden als der
gegnerischen um also größere Schäden für
die Weltwirtschaft zu vermeiden sind
Sanktion oft auf ganz bestimmte Bereiche
ausgerichtet mit anderen Worten sie
können was als Schläge mit chirurgischer
Präzision angesehen werden manchmal
werden sie gegen einzelnen Branchen oder
sogar nur einzelne Personen
ausgesprochen das ist zumindest der
Trend der letzten Jahre im Falle
Russland sprechen wir von gezielten
Maßnahmen gegen seinen Finanzsystem
seine Staatseinnahmen sind Technologie
und Militärindustrie und seine
Außerirdischen Investition
natürlich gab es Sanktionen gegen die
russische Rohstoffindustrie allerdings
hat man das mit sehr viel Augenmaß es
wurde nicht etwa der gesamte Handel mit
russischen Öl verboten und führte eine
Preisobergrenze ein warum dies den
Russen massiv schadet haben will einen
früheren Video erklärt und es dahinterte
vor allem den möglichen Zusammenbruch
des globalen Energiemarktes es geht also
um Sanktionen mit Augenmaß so viel wie
möglich und so wenig wie nötig man muss
aber ehrlicherweise zugeben das
Sanktionen leichter fallen wenn man
selbst am ökonomischen längeren Hebel
sitzt aber das ist im Falle des besten
bzw der USA praktisch immer der Fall
zumeist wenn man es mit wirtschaftlichen
Zwergen zu tun hat wie zum Beispiel den
Iran Nordkorea oder eben auch Russland
denn auch wenn sich letzteres gerne so
groß werden ist dann Wirtschaft kleiner
als die Italiens ja aber um Russland
geht es dem heutigen Video nicht es geht
um China und dieses Riesenreich ist eine
ganz andere Größenordnung es handelt
sich um nichts Geringeres als die
zweitgrößte Wirtschaftsnation der Welt
wir haben es mit einem wahren
ökonomischen Riesen zu tun kann man
China also überhaupt sanktionieren und
falls es möglich wäre würde es etwas
bringen genau das werden wir jetzt
detailliert unter die Lupe nehmen
aufgepasst
kann China sanktioniert werden
bevor wir mit unserem Thema fortfahren
würde ich euch noch gerne auf zwei Dinge
in eigene Sache hinweisen das erste ist
der neue wissenskanal cold fusion.de den
ebenfalls unser Produktionsteam
herausgibt ich werde ihn euch verlinken
denn confusion.de wird euch bestimmt
gefallen falls ihr wissenshungrig seid
und euch spannende Stories über Technik
und Wissenschaft aber auch Gesellschaft
und Wirtschaft interessieren wenn ihr
z.B alles über die gerade ablaufende
Revolution der künstlichen Intelligenz
und ihre Folgen wissen wollt auf
confusion die erfahrt ihr alle
Hintergründe und Zusammenhänge also
schaut doch mal vorbei und die zweite
Sache die ich hier gerne loswerden würde
ist meine großer Dank an alle unsere
Unterstützer ohne euch wäre das alles
was wir hier machen nicht möglich ich
spreche dabei sowohl über unsere edlen
Spender also auch all jene die sich
geduldig die Berge Einlagen unserer
Sponsoren anschauen und dann vielleicht
auch etwas von Ihnen kaufen gerade im
aktuellen wirtschaftlichen Umfeld in dem
die Werbeeinnahmen aus der normalen
erzählt Werbung auf Youtube einbrechen
stellt dies eine große wenn nicht
überlebenswichtige Hilfe da und anders
als Gebühr finanzierte Medien müssen wir
uns eben jeden Monat nur überlegen wie
wir mit dem ganzen hier über die Runden
kommen also vielen vielen herzlichen
Dank an Euch wir werden es euch mit ganz
vielen tollen Videos zurückzahlen und
bald vielleicht auch mit einem weiteren
neuen Kanal so und nun wieder zurück zu
unserem Thema die Vereinigten Staaten
und China kommen so schlecht miteinander
aus wie noch nie in den letzten
Jahrzehnten praktisch seit Richard Nixon
1972 das politische Tauwetter zwischen
den beiden Nationen eingeläutet hat lief
es nicht mehr so schlecht und das obwohl
der Handel zu stehen beiden
Völkerschaften so eng verflochten ist
die noch nie wir sprechen hier von einem
gigantischen Handelsvolumen von knapp
über 690 Milliarden Dollar pro Jahr aber
dennoch hat zwischen den beiden Mächten
längst ein Handelskrieg angefangen
[Musik]
es begann 2018 unter Donald Trump mit
imports sollen auf eine Vielzahl
chinesischer waren natürlich erhob China
im Gegenzug ebenfalls Zölle dann wieder
die USA und so weiter das ewige Ping
Pong spielt diese Handelsschranken
praktisch noch immer in Kraft auch wenn
2020 ein Handelsabkommen abgeschlossen
wurde wonach China mehr aus den USA
importieren sollte an der
grundsätzlichen Situation und an den
Zöllen endete das aber nichts die beiden
Regierung fährt jetzt einen ähnlich
harten Kurs gegen und wenn es um
Technologie geht noch einen viel
härteren am 16 September 2022 zum
Beispiel hielt Joe bidens Nationaler
Sicherheitsberater Jax Hallein eine
wichtige Rede die aufforderten ließ er
verkündete eine Änderung der
strategischen Ziele der USA man wolle
nicht nur einen technologischen
Vorsprung gegenüber den Konkurrenten
amerikasen beibehalten nein in Zukunft
sei das Ziel diesen Vorsprung so weit
wie möglich auszubauen natürlich war
China hier der Adresse hat es gibt
derzeit kein anderes Land das die USA
herausfordert die nationale
Sicherheitsstrategie der USA beschränkt
sich also nun nicht mehr nur darauf in
Führung zu bleiben sondern sie will ihre
technologische Überlegenheit viel
stärker ausbauen kostet es was es wolle
diese verschärfte Marschrichtung
erklärte dann auch solche Nachrichten
siebte Oktober
22 beiden Regierung erschwert Chinas
Zugang zu Chip-Technologie das Weiße
Haus hat weitreichende Beschränkungen
für den Verkauf von Halbleitern und
Anlagen zur Chip Herstellung an China
erlassen das soll den Zugang des Landes
zu kritischen Technologien begrenzen 9
Oktober 2022 USA wollen
technologieinvestitionen in China
einschränken die Regierung beiden
bereitet neue Regeln vor die Investition
mit US-Dollar in China einschränken
würden Joe Biden Ellis für sogenannte
US-Personen auch eine Beschränkung in
der chinesischen schick und Hightech
Industrie zu arbeiten dies betrifft
sowohl US Staatsbürger als auch Inhaber
von US Greencards und generell in den
USA ansässige Personen der Punkt ist das
dies tatsächlich auf eine große Zahl von
führungs- und kritischen Fachkräften
chinesische Halbleiterunternehmen
zutrifft im Ausland geborene Ingenieure
so wie Chinesen mit ausländischen Pass
oder Wohnsitz spielen seit langem eine
wichtige Rolle beide technologischen
Entwicklung des Landes Huawei zum
Beispiel gelang ist eine Entwicklung zu
beschleunigen und zum iPhone
aufzuschließen indem es 2015 ehemalige
Kreativdirektorin von Apple als
Chefdesignerin einstellte das
Unternehmen rekrutierte auch
international um seine interne Chip und
Audiotechnik sowie die 5
g-mobilfunktechnologie auszubauen und
weil führen und chinesischen
Halbleiterhersteller piotech waren sechs
der sieben wichtigsten Führungskräfte im
Bereich Forschung und Entwicklung
US-Bürger die personalbeschränkung der
beiden administrationshilfe also darauf
ab dass China den großen erfahrungs- und
talentbuch der USA nicht mehr so einfach
anzapfen kann und dann schafften es die
USA auch noch weitere Länder auf ihre
Seite zu ziehen 30 Januar 2023 Japan und
die Niederlande schließen sich in
amerikanischen einfuhrstoffs von Schiff
nach China an diese Allianz ist wirklich
stark es handelt sich um die drei Länder
die derzeit führen sind in der
Produktion modernster Fertigungsanlagen
für Chips in gewisser Weise handelt es
sich also schon um eine Sanktion oder
ein Embargo die USA verhindern dass die
fortschrittlichsten Mikrochips nach
China kommen oder dort hergestellt
werden können und das ist extrem wichtig
wenn man hier noch den Vorsprung West
liche Technologie bewahren kann
[Musik]
Chinas führender einheimischer
Chiphersteller smi.c produziert Chips
die mehrere Generationen hinter den
besten Modellen des Westens zurückliegen
SMI Ziel stellt derzeit 14 Nanometer
Chips her und hat kürzlich erklärt dass
es möglicherweise kleine Mengen von 7
Nanometer Chips produzieren wird das
taiwanesische TSMC und koreanische
Samsung stellten bereits in großen
Umfang Chips mit fünf und drei Nanometer
her und ein fünften Nanometer Mikrochip
ist etwa 3 mal schneller und effizienter
als sie 14 Nanometer Variante
damit China dieses Niveau erreichen kann
bräuchte es natürlich die Maschinen die
eine solche Produktion ermöglichen zum
Beispiel die extrem ultraviolet
Lithographie Maschinen des
niederländischen Unternehmens esml das
ist nämlich das modernste Unternehmen in
diesem Bereich wenn man China von dieser
Technologie abschneidet verzögert sich
seine technologische Entwicklung um
viele Jahre
30 März 2023 Amerikas handelssanktion
gegen China könnten noch viel schlimmer
werden und China könnte sich in gleicher
Weise revanchieren bevor die neuen
Regeln im Oktober in Kraft traten galt
die ganze memory technologies
Corporation ymtc einen großer staatliche
Hersteller von Speicherchips weithin als
das chinesische Unternehmen mit den
besten Chancen eine globale Kraft in der
chip-herstellung zu werden doch über
Nacht wurde die Unternehmen in allen
anderen chinesischen Firmen der Kauf von
Anlagen untersagt die sich für die
Herstellung der modernsten Schiffs
benötigen die Folgen davon wirken sich
auch auf die Lieferketten aus why MTC
kann keine Produktionslinie mit
ausländischen Komponenten mehr bauen was
bedeutet dass es Aufträge für chines
Ausrüstung stornieren muss das
Unternehmen wird nicht mehr in der Lage
sein chip-bestellungen chinesischer
Kunden zu erfüllen im Januar begann es
mit der Entlassung von Beschäftigten die
bereits erlassenen Sanktionen werden
dazu führen dass Chinas Chip Industrie
Jahre zurückgeworfen wird wurde zuvor
geschätzt dass China bis 2030 etwa die
Hälfte seines typbedarfs selbst
befriedigen kann musste diese Prognose
nun auf ein Drittel gekürzt werden das
Ziel der beiden Regierung scheint also
aufzugehen im Gegensatz zu früheren
Maßnahmen ziehen sie nämlich nicht nur
darauf ab den Zugang zu
fortschrittlichen Waffen oder ähnlichen
Technologien einzuschränken sondern
ganze Branchen in ihrer Entwicklung im
Jahre zurückzuwerfen und technologisch
endgültig abzuhängen als nächstes werden
die Amis die Exportbeschränkungen so
erweitern dass die Rechenleistung der
chinesischen Chips und ihre
kommunikationsgeschwindigkeit mit
anderen Komponenten leidet ebenfalls im
Visier ist die chinesische Fachmann
Branche die bis 2025 ein Umsatz von mehr
als 100 Milliarden Dollar erzielen soll
auch sie ist in hohem Maße von
amerikanischen Innovationen abhängig
US-Firmen liefern viele die Herstellung
neuer Medikamente benötigte Dinge an
chinesische Firmen und
Forschungseinrichtungen auf der
potenziellen stouseliste steht Software
biologische Materialien Laborausrüstung
technische Informationen und
Forschungsdaten alles Dinge die zur
Herstellung von Medikamenten und zur
Entwicklung neuer Behandlungsmethoden
benötigt werden die medizinische
versorgungslos sanktionieren Marc Marc
haberklingen sie ist jedoch gerade im
überalternden von Umweltverschmutzung
und ungesunden Ernährungsgewohnheiten
geplagten China eine bedeutende und
strategische Achillesferse aber apropos
Ernährung und makaberer Achillesferse
China ist eines der wenigen großen
Länder der Welt das ist nicht schafft
seine Bevölkerung aus heimischer
Produktion dazu bekommen und das Problem
wird immer schlimmer
China ist immer mehr von importierten
Lebensmitteln abhängig und das ist ein
Problem bislang konnte ich ihnen seine
1,4 Milliarden Menschen ernähren aber
der Klimawandel und die Abhängigkeit von
Importen könnten eine Herausforderung
darstellen china ist in den letzten zwei
Jahrzehnten immer stärker von
Lebensmittelimporten abhängig geworden
was die Sorge begründet das
Unterbrechungen der
lebensmittelversorgungsketten unhun im
Land auslösen könnten trotz heimischer
Produktion ist China seit 2004 ein Netto
Importeur von Agrarprodukten heute
importiert ist eine größere Menge dieser
Produkte als jedes andere Land dazu
zählen auch Grundnahrungsmittel wie
Sojabohnen meistens und Milchprodukte
zwischen 2000 und 2020 sagt der
Selbstversorgungsgrad des Landes vorne
93,6 % auf 65,8 % und ausgerechnet genau
an diesem Punkt setzt die beiden
Regierung auch an Anfang März kündigte
das US-Landwirtschaftsministerium an
eine Arbeitsgruppe zur Förderung des
fairen Wettbewerbs in der Salzindustrie
zu bilden Ziel ist auch hier bei
natürlich der Expansion der chinesischen
Agrarindustrie auszubremsen vor allem
ins Ausland allein aufgrund dieser
Ankündigung fielen die Anleihen des
chinesischen agrarindustrie-konzerns
sinochamp da dieser jahrelang
Technologien und Unternehmen in Übersee
erworben hatte zum Beispiel in Schweizer
agrargiganten Syngenta für 43 Milliarden
Dollar und die Sanktionen gegen
sinochamp könnten nun dazu führen dass
seine Auslandsgesellschaften in den Ruin
getrieben werden wie ihr seht haben wir
es hier schon mit ziemlich kritischen
Folgen zu tun aber kann der Westen noch
weitergehen zum Beispiel für den Fall
dass seine aggressive Außenpolitik
weiter vorantreibt oder Taiwan angreift
was könnte die Regierung die beiden
diese Politik wirklich erreichen schauen
wir uns dazu mal die folgende Übersicht
an
[Musik]
wie auf dem Bildschirm sehen könnt gibt
es mehrere Arten von Sanktionen die
beiden wichtigsten und wirkungsvollsten
sind unserer Meinung nach Finanz- und
handelskontrollen letzterer wären zum
Beispiel Ausfuhrkontrollen für
technische Güter wie etwa Hightech was
finanzielle Sanktion angeht könnten die
USA damit drohen Chinas Vermögen
einzufrieren so wie sie es bereits mit
Russland getan haben denn im Vergleich
zum chinesischen Auslandsvermögen
handelt es sich beim russischen umreine
Peanuts china hat mehr als sage und
schreibe drei Billionen Dollar anderer
Reserven in den USA und bei US
Verbündeten liegen aber wäre ein solcher
Schritt wirklich realistisch nun
mittelfristig handelt es sich um eine
eher schlechte Idee erstens natürlich
weil es die Anziehungskraft des bestens
für ausländisches Kapital verringern
würde viele andere Länder könnten es
nämlich als Risiko betrachten unter
diesen Umständen Geld in Amerika oder
bei seinem Verbündeten Zulagen außerdem
könnte ich ihn dann darauf reagieren
indem sie westliche Investition in
seinem Land beschlagen hat und wie hoch
fallen diese aus nach Angaben der Center
Forstwirtschaft international studies
handelt es sich um 3,6 Billionen
US-Dollar an Direktinvestitionen und 2,2
Billionen US-Dollar an Aktien Anleihen
und ähnlichen Finanzanlagen unterm
Strich wäre dies also mehr als das
eingefrorene Auslandsvermögen was beim
ökonomisch rückständigen und global
weniger bedeutenden Russland möglich war
hätte im Falle Chinas also viel ernstere
Konsequenzen man würde sich seine
eigenen Finger verbrennen aber es gebe
noch eine andere Art von finanzamtionen
und zwar die Geschäfte chinesischer
Banken mit internationalen Banken diese
zu unterbinden wäre so etwas wie die
ökonomischen atomknopf zu drücken diese
Maßnahme würde den Handel mit China zum
Erliegen bringen denn es ist klar dass
wenn man für den Warenaustausch nicht
bezahlen kann er logischerweise nicht
mehr stattfinden wird selbst die
Einführung kleinere Beschränkungen wie
der Swift Ausschluss hätte erhebliche
Auswirkungen für China aber auch für die
westlichen Länder selbst man wäre
plötzlich mit einem riesigen Mangel an
allen möglichen Produkten konfrontiert
Lieferketten während futsch es wäre das
total chaos viele westliche Unternehmen
würden zusammenbrechen und in flation
würde durch die Decke gehen das was wir
bisher eine Inflation gesehen haben wäre
nur ein kleines Vorspiel denn China ist
nun mal der größte exporter der Welt die
Werkbank im Reich der Mittel produziert
so viel an waren wie die Vereinigten
Staaten und Europa zusammengenommen also
nein derartige Strafmaßnahmen sind keine
gute Idee es würde die Welt von einem
Tag auf den anderen völlig auf den Kopf
stellen
[Musik]
erinnert ihr euch noch an vorhin als wir
über den Beginn des handelskonflikts
zwischen den USA und China gesprochen
haben selbst die begrenzten für
chinesische Waren haben dem
amerikanischen Verbraucher eher
geschadet als genutzt sie gelten daher
auch als einer der größten Flops in der
Bilanz der trump-regierung nach
Schätzungen der Zentralbank von New York
zahlt jeder us-haushalt wegen Trumps
Zöllen durchschnittlich 830 $ zusätzlich
pro Jahr einfach deshalb weil man
gewisse günstige chinesische Waren nicht
mehr in den USA kaufen kann ihr also was
passieren würde wenn es nichts mehr aus
China günstig zu kaufen gebe unser Leben
wäre viel teurer und viele Produkte
werden für eine Zeit lang einfach weg
kurz gesagt es bleiben uns nur zwei
mögliche Maßnahmen bei der ersten muss
der Westen wo dosiert und in kleinen
Schritten vorgehen es geht darum Chinas
Präsenz in den internationalen
Produktionsketten schrittweise zur
reduzieren mit anderen Worten die
Produktionsstätten westliche Konzerne in
andere Länder zu verlagern und sich
nicht nur auf China zu verlassen das
Problem ist dass dies ein sehr langer
unter langsamer Prozess ist eine zweite
Maß Name besteht darin den Zugang
Pekings zu bestimmten Importen und
Technologien punktuell zu beschränken
siehe unsere schon erwähnten Beispiele
mit den Mikrochips und der
Pharma-Branche aber hier muss man genau
aufpassen was man tut denn Chinas
Fabriken müssen weiter all das
produzieren können was für den besten
nützlich und unverzichtbar ist darüber
hinaus sollte das Riesenreich nicht so
weit in die Enge getrieben werden dass
es keinen anderen Ausweg mehr sieht als
die gewaltsame Konfrontation vergessen
wenn ich das China eine ambitionierte
Atom macht ist China erwägt seinen
Bestand an Atom Sprengköpfen bis 2035
auf 900 zu verdreifachen da die Spannung
mit den Vereinigten Staaten wegen Taiwan
weiter eskalieren dürften eine Blockade
ihrer Öllieferungen wäre z.B nicht sehr
sinnvoll sie würde dich chinesische
Produktion extrem verlangsamen eine
globale Krise Auslösung vielleicht sogar
zu einem Krieg führen und ist es ein
Problem dass China die Werkbank der Welt
ist nun zum Teil ja aber genau das ist
auch seine Achillesferse
[Musik]
es stimmt dass China gigantische Mengen
an waren exportiert aber genau dafür
verschlingt es auch riesige Mengen an
Produkten aus dem Ausland neben Öl und
allen möglichen Rohstoffen importiert
das Land vor allem mikroschützen andere
hochtechnologische Produkte und wer sind
die Hauptlieferanten und das sind vor
allem Japan Südkorea die Vereinigten
Staaten Taiwan Deutschland und einige
andere westliche Länder sie sind es die
die chinesischen Technologie Importe
dominieren China braucht westliche
Technik um ein Wirtschaftsmotor dieser
Welt zu sein daher könnte eine
Beschränkung des Zugang zu
Spitzentechnologien starkes Hemmnis für
Shisha banks aggressive Außenpolitik
darstellen der fehlende Zugang zu
Hightech dürfte z.B die militärischen
Fähigkeit der Chinesen gegenüber dem das
bestens einschränken
[Musik]
um es also nochmal zusammenzufassen kann
China scharf und vollumfänglich
sanktioniert werden im Großen und Ganzen
nein die Medizin könnte sie hier als
schlimmer erweisen als die Krankheit
denn Chinas Rolle in der Weltwirtschaft
ist mittlerweile zu wichtig was sie doch
getan werden könnte ist ihre Entwicklung
zu verlangsamen indem man ihren Zugang
zu spitzentlichen Login und bestimmten
Produkten verhindert außerdem würde dies
viele Unternehmen dazu veranlassen ihre
Produktionslinien nach und nach aus
China zu verlagern man will ja nach wie
vor mit modernen Mitteln produzieren vor
allem langfristig wäre das die beste
Option um nicht von den launischen Dings
oder ähnliche Diktatoren abhängig zu
sein denn man hat ja gesehen wozu
Abhängigkeiten von Diktatoren führen
genauso wie es von vielen westlichen
Ländern äußerst dumm war sich von
russischen Rohstoffen abhängig zu machen
ist es ebenfalls unklug sich bei
einfachen und oft auch komplexen
Industrieprodukten allein auf China zu
verlassen Ganze sicher ist jetzt die
beste und auch höchste Zeit dafür
genauso solche Maßnahmen zu ergreifen
man sollte hier keine Zeit verlieren den
produktionsverl agerungen sind eine
langwierige und auch teure Angelegenheit
[Musik]
natürlich müssen die USA und ihre
Verbündeten auch ordentlich Gas geben
was ihre eigene technologische
Entwicklung angeht das würde eine
Politik erfordern die Anreize für
Unternehmen und Investitionen bietet
inklusive der aggressiven Anwerbung von
Talenten und Fachkräften kurzum es geht
um klassische Industriepolitik in den
USA scheint man das umzusetzen in
Deutschland und in Europa da braucht es
wohl noch ein bisschen aber das ist
schon wieder ein Thema für ein anderes
Video aber am Ende stellt sich noch eine
große Frage nämlich ob die Technologie
Sanktionen am Ende nicht genau das
ankurbeln was sie verhindern sollen die
Entwicklung strategische chinesischer
Industrien nun china könnte versuchen
aufzuholen aber die gute Nachricht für
den besten ist das ist immer noch weit
hinterher hängt die Kommunistische
Partei investiert war viele Ressourcen
des Landes um in Schlüsselindustrien
autark zu werden das Geld wird häufig
jedoch sehr ineffizient eingesetzt ihre
Maßnahmen schaffen es nicht die
Produktivität in dem Maße zu erhöhen wie
dies in den USA der Fall ist sie ist in
seiner Industriepolitik eher ein Freund
großer staatlicher Unternehmen denn die
kann man besser kontrollieren allerdings
sind diese nur Loche kaum innovativ und
flexibel und schrecklich ineffizient von
Korruption ganz zu schweigen das Land
ist außerdem insgesamt hoffnungslos
überaltert und leidet unter einer
enormen Abwanderung von Talenten mit
anderen Worten die Strategie der wohl
dosierten Importbeschränkungen und
schrittweise Produktionsverlagerung
konnte tatsächlich funktionieren und
selbst wenn sie die chinesische
Regierung nicht von ihrer Agenda
abbringt könnte sie zumindest ihre
internationale Handlungsfähigkeit
einschränken dies zumindest scheint die
aktuelle geostrategische Einschätzung in
Washington zu sein wenn man weiß dass
sich Peking im Augenblick kaum wehren
kann strategische Vergeltungsmaßnahmen
gegenüber den USA kann es sich nicht
leisten im Gegenteil die chinesische
Führung ist froh das große amerikanische
Unternehmen wie Apple oder Tesla in
ihrem Land expandieren die Abhängigkeit
ist einfach zu groß China würde sich mit
gegen Sanktionen viel mehr Schaden als
den USA wir behalten die Entwicklung
weiterhin im Auge um euch auf dem
laufenden zu halten vergesst also bitte
nicht das Abo mit Glöckchen und wenn ihr
das erledigt ist wie immer erstmal eure
Meinung gefragt haltet ihr die
beschriebene Strategie für sinnvoll
glaubt ihr das Chinas Zugang zum
westlicher Technologie weiter
eingeschränkt werden sollte und wie
könnte die chinesische Regierung
reagieren wie immer sind wir auch
Diskussion zu diesem Thema schon mächtig
gespannt ich hoffe dass euch dieses
Video gefallen hat und ihr vielleicht
auch das dabei gelernt habt falls ja
geht uns bitte ein Like Pets mit unseren
Freunden und diskutiert es mit ihnen
natürlich wollen wir uns auch die gesagt
jederzeit über eine Spende von euch mit
der uns hält dieses Projekt
weiterzuführen den Link dazu findet ihr
in der Beschreibung unter dem Video
macht's gut und bis bald
[Musik]